something very surprising happen which
I'm sure a lot of people are going to be
shocked with Mike Pence was boot at the
NRA what yeah he was did you hear about
that yeah
it was in his home state and again and
Trump got a two-minute uh Standing
Ovation at the event uh in his speech
first speech since being indicted on
felony charges New York Trump promised
to remain a loyal friend and fearless uh
champion of the country's largest gun
rights lobbying group as he seeks to be
the party's nominee for 2024
presidential election he appeared to
acknowledge the crowd's frosty response
depends his former running mate the NRA
event was attended by several Republican
hopefuls including Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis and former United Nations
Ambassador Nikki Haley highlighting how
the NRA's endorsement remains powerful
and highly coveted amongst Republicans
how important is the NRA endorsement by
the way it's big it's it's it's very
important I think that's why ironically
your boy desans put out his anti-trump
your boy your boy his anti-trump ad I
want to say the same day saying Trump
was bad on the Second Amendment because
I mean NRA guns like that's it's a lot
bigger than people realize yeah
it's pretty wild you know you know how
you think about NRA right now if if
somebody is member of NRA it's kind of
like oh my god did you know yeah he's
part of the NRA how could you be part of
the NRA and uh John F Kennedy was a
proud card carrying member of the NRA it
was a very normal thing back in the days
both the Dems and the Republicans wanted
the endorsement now it's just on the
right uh when it comes down to this but
what if you were to say Mike Pence where
will he peek okay one let's say he runs
okay how like what percent do you think
is going to be his Peak like you know
remember Herman Cain went all the way up
I think he had 18 at one point Newton
went to 23 or Sanders got to 20 21 you
know or so Ross Pro got to 19 or 20 but
what do you think Pence is going to go
to well I'll give you I'll give you two
answers here
um number one I think you know High
single digits maybe it's you know seven
eight nine percent at best right right
now it's two percent but but we all know
let me tell you who I think Mike Pence
is going to be
you know uh when it's uh you know it's
NBA season right now and you know like
let's say uh you know the Dallas
Mavericks need to win their final game
in order to make the playoffs and
they're playing against the Houston
Rockets and Houston's been long out of
the playoffs they got no chance but they
want to beat the out of Dallas Yeah
okay or it's like the Miami Dolphins
they're not making the playoffs if
they're playing the Patriots and all
they want to do is be a spoiler and they
don't care their season's done they know
that they're not winning but they have
their sights on winning that last game
of the season why to ruin the Patriots
season to ruin Dallas Maverick season we
just saw Dallas get eliminated from the
playoffs
I don't think we understand the Vendetta
that Mike Pence has against Donald Trump
I don't think we're gonna fully realize
that until it gets so ugly on that
debate stage with Trump
with DeSantis with Pence possibly with
Chris Christie we know Nikki Haley will
be there Tim Scott
we're going to see Mike Pence on stage
saying I was his vice president he
endangered my life and my family he is
unfit to be president
if you don't think that's gonna
he's gonna do it of course he is and I
still think that Trump will get the
nomination of course but it's gonna but
what may happen this is just my opinion
tear it down all you want is that it's
going to get so ugly and ugly and ugly
that there's going to be a wounded
candidate coming into the general
election and sleepy ass Joe Biden is
just gonna Sleep Walk potentially into
the presidency because it's gonna be so
much fighting on the Republican side of
things oh that's my opinion but when you
see people like the pen systems like you
know you have Z the hell with that two
percent you have zero chance of touching
Trump let alone the sentence so I think
all those people on that stage are
either put there strategically just like
you said to make them look like so
that the left even is going to learn
more stuff about them to give them
talking points to talk you know
you're losing that race but Trump is
Trump is number one right now
nobody's touching like so those people
is it just for their resume Pat like I
ran for president in 2024. you're it's a
it's a lost battle before you even go in
like what are you what are you doing you
know you know what I mean why are you
announcing for what listen if you if
you've gone in that world yeah of the
world of politics
and you're gonna plan on writing a book
or Legacy Kids you have to have your
Wikipedia say former 2024 presidential
candidate got you like if if if I was
any one of you that are born here yeah
at one point you have to figure out a
way to run for president and to say
Vincent oshana 2032
presidential candidate former
presidential uh you know candidate can I
get it for 2000 can we do it for this
one I don't know if we can do it what
let's do it I think I think that's a
part of it the other part of it as well
is
a lot of these guys run because they get
a job afterwards so there's a job that
you're fighting for uh remember when
Trump won the day he won you know
they're like well typically when a you
know candidate wins you know they take a
week off or a month off or they don't do
anything the guy was in the office the
next day I love it and he was
interviewing Romney that walked into his
office I don't know if you remember what
Romney walked into this office you're
like yeah what the hell is Romney doing
and everybody's just meeting meaning
meeting because this is like hey do you
want a job let's talk about it do you
want this shot let's talk about I'll
give you this job well if I give you
this job are you gonna so that's kind of
like the next part so meanwhile Joe's
sleeping ninety percent of people are
running for a job they're not running to
be president what job would Mike Pence
be running for at this point though he's
already been vice president he's already
been Governor it's easy to take shots at
Mike Pence but same people that like
Trump forget that he played a very
important role uh at that time because
he brought in the side of where he was
the Indiana I want to say you know
conservative safe and some people that
were like man I'm a little worried about
him he brought more safety in like you
know when I started an insurance company
I had a reputation of being very
competitive you know loud you know doing
my thing and I upset a lot of different
people I brought certain people in that
got those that were worried about coming
over to us to say okay that guy's there
they're gonna be fine that guy's there I
feel safer so it's a strategic hire that
you have so you can take shots at him
all you want the guy was a hero for a
lot of trump fans back in 2015-26 yeah
and I think he played his partner it's
like a player you got that you forget
Ray Allen hit the shot he got a
championship game yes just give him the
credit I hate Ray Allen as much as you
want today I get it but the guy still
hit the shot got you chips you could
make the case that he got Trump elected
because he won over the Christian event
he was very important I think it was
very important what I don't like now
is that sometimes this is what happens
is okay who's more important Pence or
Trump to get into the White House who's
more important who's the bigger driver
to get into today not even a
conversation give me the percentage of
them when they won in 2016. what
percentage of 2016. what percentage of
the credit of trump winning was Trump
what percentage of the credit of uh
Trump going to the White House was Pence
25 no way guys what are you talking
about 90 10. it's in it's 99 to 1.
really yeah because you you didn't win
the what do you call it the the primary
by you know you want it because it's
like this is the guy right and then you
announce who it is so it's 99 him it's
one him here's the problem
you know if you wrote on someone's
coattail and you go up and you flip it's
it's a it's a little bit that's what his
DNA is today that's his reputation today
uh you know and by the way Democrats
love them CNN loves him MSNBC loves him
he's a great tool by the way expect him
to be on TV 60 Minutes CBS ABC all of
this stuff for for 16 straight months
every day and then he's going to get a
10 million dollar book deal 5 million
dollar book deal and then he's going to
be the guy that's going to have a
consultant you know half a million
dollar a year job with CNN MSNBC to do
talking yeah that's what he's going to
be doing so but it is what it is he
played it's like it's like a Scottie
Pippen I was watching a video today
about how Scottie Pippen was um
the guy in and after the Last Dance
there was a big follow now between the
two of them yeah because Scotty then
came out and he wrote a book and he said
what he says what do you want to be
remembered as I want to be remembered as
the greatest of all time dude come on
bro that's what he wants to Scotty said
I want to be remembered have you seen
this interview
I want to be remembered as a solution
when when Robin suddenly thinks
he's Batman yes
you're going to be a better Robin being
the best Robin you can be correct versus
you all of a sudden thinking you know
anyways this just took me to a
completely let me asking questions it's
delusional you actually think you said
that CNN you know these msnbcs they love
Pence now you actually think they love
him I think they look at him as a useful
idiot well but that's do you still love
a useful idiot of course they're like oh
uh Trump's boot licking VP is now
anti-trump it's Saturday night 11
o'clock yeah three people aren't texting
you back one of the girls does
you love her
you love him I'm just trying to give you
an analogy that you relate to yeah Adam
just went to this last Saturday so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]